dans sa brique doris est une très
vieille connaissance de la berri lee a
joué jusqu'en 2001 puis l'a entraîné à
deux reprises d'ailleurs entre 2003 et
2005 c'était avec la réserve puis avec
l'équipe première de 2006 à février 2008
avant de partir au havre il connaît donc
bien la ville le club les supporters
tout cela et est plutôt de bonne augure
c'est un atout sur le papier mais il ya
quand même deux bémols d'abord cédric
daury et bien il est sorti par la petite
porte en 2008 limogé faute de résultats
même punition au havre en 2012 il était
sans contrat depuis alors ça par contre
ce n'est pas forcément de bon augure
même si l'entraîneur ne peut pas tout
notamment si les joueurs sont faibles
bien sûr et puis deuxièmement il à la
situation quasi désespérée du club de la
berri qui est 19ème de ligue 2 à 6
points du premier non relégable
valenciennes grosse pression donc sur
cédric daury qui sera sur le terrain à
l'entraînement dès cet après midi à
15h30 benoît